[Music]
what's up webhead I'm your host this
week spider walks and this is top five
today we swing into action with a
beloved animated series from the night
this episode is the result of a Twitter
poll that went up on awesome underscore
Walt Moore polled will be going up on
there soon so if you want your voice
heard
make sure you follow this very show is
responsible for introducing me to
spider-man and launch my interest in
comics spider-man the animated series of
the show that aired on Fox kids from
1994 to 1998 it's regarded by many as
one of the best interpretations of the
wall-crawler today it always felt close
to its comic-book origins and was very
creative in inventing variations on
certain storylines and characters that
made it stand out not saying the show
was perfect but it's the first thing
that pops in my head when I think of
Spidey
and have stood the test of time on a few
different levels but if you're going
back to rewatch the show which by the
way should be released on DVD and
blu-ray in the US these stories are a
great place to start here are the top
five best episodes of spider-man the
animated series number five the six
forgotten warriors chapters three
through five from season five this spot
might be a little confusing this is
actually a five part but the first two
episodes aren't the best and not
essential to what makes this art great
you'll be just fine watching Chapter
three secrets of the sixth chapter for
the sixth fight again and Chapter five
the price of heroism these episodes
cover a lot early on it's about clearing
Peters parents names but the best stuff
involved the backstory on Captain
America and the six American warriors
after the serum that created Captain
America was lost American scientists
still try to recreate the same effects
from scratch as World War two dragged on
while they weren't able to exactly
duplicate taps powers they were
successful in instilling five
extraordinary Americans with temporary
powers unique from one another they were
all given individual keys to protect a
Nazi doomsday device that was created by
the Red Skull and his team in
present-day
kingpin reformed the insidious six to
obtain the doomsday web
but is intercepted by the red skull son
who resurrects the red skull with the
help of a former Nazi scientist he
kidnapped
despite Captain America also being
brought back from the same vortex Red
Skull escaped from the doomsday device
is unleashed as the all-powerful electro
now Spider Man Captain America and the
American warriors must stop this
ultimate weapon and put bread skull away
for good this alteration on the Captain
America story introduced several new
characters while expanding the lore of
the show's mythology this is where the
story begins
that shield it looks just like the one
that belong to in America the story of
the six American warriors began in 1942
adding capture the series near the end
here was pretty awesome to see he had
appeared in a flashback in a previous
episode but this was the first time we
saw him interact with Spidey and others
in present day also how he was preserved
in his physical prime and directly tied
to Red Skull was a clever change from
his actual origin we are evenly matched
that day maybe but I can see to it
you're not around to activate to the
trust Captain America himself so that
the doomsday device would never be used
the concept of the six American warriors
is one that was truly interesting seeing
them revive their old powers and reteam
with tap in their twilight years was a
fun story element to see play out
they became destroy a Miss America
Thunderer the black Marvel and the
wizard with kappas our leader they were
to be called the six American warriors
the end game for Red Skull here was to
finally let loose his doomsday weapon
and seeing that turn out to be a lecture
was an unexpected twist electro is a
classic Spidey villain so it was good to
see him finally show up even if it
wasn't the characters mainstream origin
however this version absolutely worked
for the store behold my doomsday weapon
a soldier who can harness energy and
bend it to his will he is no longer my
son now you may call him
[Music]
in the end this was an ambitious
large-scale narrative that had
spider-man learned more about his world
and changed him for the better as a hero
and leader this was a great storyline
involving flashbacks to World War two
but it's not the best war-themed arc in
the series number four secret wars
chapters one through three from season
five this was a dream come true for a
lot of longtime Marvel fans the
adaptation of this famous comic book
saga was contained in these three
episode titled the arrival the gauntlet
of the Red Skull and doom the test
Madame web has been telling spider-man
about has finally arrived her superior
the Beyonder is revealed to spider-man
as he wants to see which is stronger
good or evil the Beyonder transports
the lizard Alistair Smythe the Red
Skull and dr. doomed to a peaceful alien
planet and fast forwards one year now
the planet has been taken over by the
villains and it's up to spider-man to
save it or perish trying he's allowed to
bring his own teams of the planet and
decide on the Fantastic Four Iron Man
Captain America and storm the fate of
this planet is on the line as good and
evil engage in the Ultimate Bet I'm sure
this caused a lot of viewers to nerd out
as we got plenty of Marvel characters
fighting in a huge planet-sized war one
little tidbit I love from these episodes
is how they awoke dr. Connors
consciousness in the lizard's body Peter
and Connors friendship is a rich one in
this show and I really enjoyed seeing
Curt fight alongside spider-man in this
big adventure
[Music]
we're have a spider-man what's going on
it's okay doc you're here amongst
friends in the finale we did a great
character story involving Doctor Doom
and the thing doom
tears Ben Grimm of his rocky appearance
and this has the thing defending his
greatest enemy against his own friend
old Doc T changed me back just like I
always wanted how did he do that Doc's
got some sort of power separator watch
this I can transform whenever I want to
pretty neat huh
later after doom absorbs the Beyonder
and his powers
spider-man attempts to appeal to any
humanity left in doom and one of the
best dialogue exchanges in the series
who amongst you has ever wanted to give
up their super powers I have because
I've learned time and time again that
with great power there must also come
great responsibility and that's a
responsibility even you can't avoid I do
not wish to avoid it this turned out to
be just a warm-up as the real war was
about to begin for Spidey and the series
started to wrap up number 3 the alien
costume parts 1 through 3 from season 1
this was a big deal introducing black
suit Spidey and venom to the series the
alien costume is not only three of the
best episodes of the show they also
might be the most memorable after a
space mission led by Jay jonah Jameson
son John crashes back to earth
spider-man swoops in to save the day
later he realizes a black substance from
the shuttle has attached itself to him
it augments his strength and changes
this costume as time goes on however
Peter finds out the suit is actually an
alien symbiote that amplifies his
aggression and rage pushing him to do
things he normally would after expelling
it from his body the symbiote finds a
new host in Peter's enemy Eddie Brock
and together they form venom
spider-man's deadliest foe to date all
these years later
I still remember almost everything about
these episodes beat for beat that's how
strong of an impression it had on me and
many fans of the show who doesn't
remember this iconic scene
ah what a nightmare
her second thought was great use of
visuals to tell what's happening with
Peter it worked perfectly now
Christopher Daniel Barnes got to really
go all out with his voice acting here
Peter was getting lost in his rage and
this created some really cool and kind
of scary moments from our hero you can't
escape me I'll chase you to the edge of
the belt our scene is absolutely iconic
the setting the atmosphere it's all
still vivid in my brain
[Music]
directly following that was the creation
of bed
[Music]
after an initial battle Peter sees venom
everywhere and since Eddie knows his
alter-ego as spider-man thanks to the
symbiote this causes all of Peters
friends and family to be threatened
Spidey has to outsmart venom to defeat
him and it's a big challenge to see
spider-man go through also the third
episode has this scene in check it out -
smashes I'm spider-man
check it out I'm spider-man number two
turning point from season three the
Green Goblin may very well be the best
villain on the show Norman Osborn is
descent into madness culminated in this
twisted story that is reminiscent of one
of Spidey's biggest tragedies the Green
Goblin is in almost complete control of
Norman Osborn and is now in possession
of a transporting device that allows him
to pop up anywhere he wishes and
disappeared just as fast he uses it to
find out the true identity of spider-man
and sets in motion a plan that changes
Peter Parker's life forever
this episode features a moment that the
series may be best known for it is
indeed a turning point that we never got
a 100% conclusion -
mary-jane it's the center point of the
rest of the series Peters constant
search for MJ and even more so the
effect it has on him psychologically
drives a lot of his actions
Mary Jane returns the following season
but she isn't exactly who she appears to
be after toying with Peter at Harry's
big birthday bash the Green Goblin and
spider-man eventually clash which leads
to Mary Jane's disappearance
once again the voice acting here is
unrestricted you can hear the anger in
Peter's voice as he just lost the love
of his life you think this is a game
[Music]
nothing can keep me from you Goblin
you'll pay on board if I have to chase
you forever if I can happen obviously
similar to the death of Gwen Stacy in
the comics this episode solidify the
series as something great it's
absolutely the best single episode of
the show I still really love this show
even with multi partners making their
way into the top 5 that still doesn't
make enough room to show off just how
good this show really is so here are
some more great episodes as honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best episode of
spider-man the animated series is spider
Wars chapters 1 & 2 from season 5 these
two episodes
I really really hate clones and farewell
spider-man were the series finale of the
show and man were they epic immediately
following Secret Wars the Beyonder and
Madame web revealed a spider-man that
the real war begins now spider men from
different parallel universes are brought
together to stop the multiverse from
being destroyed entirely things are made
even more complicated when the
mastermind behind the destruction of
reality is shown to be Peter Parker
himself this was a brilliant way to end
the series and did so in amazing
spectacular fashion this is a great
testament to how good the show could be
with balancing seemingly complex
storylines and making them very simple
and easy to follow without sacrificing
their intelligence or emotional
character corpse the Easter eggs both
subtle and not in these episodes are
fantastic and we get to see Peter and
Ben Reilly team up and glorious nineties
animation my name is Ben Riley I related
to this realities Peter Parker
I'm his clone but the next big blow came
from dr. Curt Connors he discovered it
according to our genetic structures it
might be Peter who was the clone me this
is starting to sound like a bad comic
book plot no comment the villain here is
Peter from Ben's universe after being
taken over by carnage this is also
pretty much the worst case scenario
about Peters life as spider-man could
have played out a little later we travel
to iron spider suit Peter's universe
where life turned out perfectly for
Parker Uncle Ben never died he's a
billionaire and his wife is Gwen Stacy I
always thought that was a fascinating
little tidbit the name's Gwen Stacy how
Peter takes down spider-carnage is this
show at its best
Spidey gets this universes Uncle Ben to
come appeal to the remaining good inside
of him it's a phenomenal moment that
pops almost anything in the series you
remember what I taught you about great
power yes with great powers there was to
it great responsibility Peter there's an
evil inside you it's your responsibility
to the world and yourself to expel it
but the greatness doesn't end there we
even get to see spider-man interact with
his co-creator excuse me I'm looking for
some guy named Stanley what why your man
Pam hold my calls for a while I think I
finally got crazy one of my favorite
appearances stan has done plus with the
recent death of his wife and the voice
of Madame web Joan Lee this scene feels
even more special
who is that exotic lady let Stanley he's
quite a guy I think he's truly special
well madam with where to now face front
true believer many people remember the
show finally and for good reason in my
opinion with a few caveats it holds up
very very well and it's a great place
for new and old spider-man fans to find
enjoyment in this timeless character I
want to hear what you guys think
what is your favorite episode of
spider-man the animated series what do
you want covered next in the show leave
a comment and let us know for more
content like the Spider Man homecoming
review subscribe to youtube.com slash
awesome Walter like facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B and follow along on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future
later webhead love that guy
grab your crystals and come back next
week as it's morphin time
once again
[Music]
you